here's one I prepared earlier on the
screen so what I've done is I've gone
from that parabola we got in the middle
it's the derivative and is by the way to
introduce some language which will only
really need to worry about later you
differentiate it once so we call it the
first derivative this guy down the
bottom you differentiate a second time
so we call it the not the first
derivative but the set I'm no amazing
right the second derivative very
creative name now have a look right the
first thing is I've got a straight line
why should that make sense with the
intuition we had before yeah ah very
good so when you look and see there's
only one station if we're just one you
should expect only a single place where
you've got a gradient of zero okay the
other thing is just very roughly
speaking the very first graph we started
with was probably cubic right probably
the next one was a after cubic what we
call it when there's a path three the
next one's power to what we call that so
we call the shape a parabola but we call
the equation a quadratic right cubic
quadratic what's next just linear a
straight line right which is exactly
what we got okay now when you have a
look at this guy you got to think a
little more carefully because what I'm
giving you now this is the middle graph
right this is the gradient now I want
you to try and work out what would the
original function the function where we
started from you can call this the
antiderivative right where'd you come
from
right I want you to have a thick I'll
give you the first clue but it's it's
not a huge clue the first clue is do you
remember when we were doing this
together from the original graph down to
the gradient we looked for stationary
points right to remember that okay
here's my clue for this one I'm not
drawing lines down I'm drawing them up
I'm going to let you see if you can work
out just from that as a bit of a nudge
drawing those lines from the gradient
function where it's zero and join them
up what might you expect to get on the
top have a go use pencil get it wrong
try something out compare with the
people next to you
okay guys let's have a look together
because this is trickier in fact some of
you may not have realized this but
you're actually learning something I
sort of visually now which you're not
gonna learn for a good like six months
algebraic you like really that advanced
okay that's why it's a bit hard right
let me show you let me walk you through
how I'm gonna think through this for
starters I started you off looking at
the graph above but maybe it might be
easier if we actually did the one below
we know how to do that we know how to
differentiate right this looks roughly
like what kind of shape it looks like a
parabola right so an x-squared
something-or-other so therefore you
should expect anticipate that the graph
below should be what kind of shape
linear a straight line very good
hopefully you've worked out by now I'll
keep on that one when you go from that
stationary point down to here you're
going to have a positive gradient over
there it's increasing and then it turns
to zero and then it gives way to a
negative gradient see that right so
that's why you should have sorry I'll
choose a darker color you should have a
straight line that looks something
roughly like so okay so that was the
easy part
but how do we go climb up the ladder
that's trickier isn't it he is the way
I'm going to do it why are these two
lines important to me these two vertical
lines hopefully wait this happened yeah
good where the gradient is zero here and
here
two spots I should expect to get two
stationary points up above does that
make sense okay and what does the
stationary point look like well if you
have a look at this graph here a
stationary point is kind of like this
flat part here
do you agree in fact if I zoomed in far
enough that's what they would just look
like a horizontal line just for a teeny
little instant time okay so what I'm
gonna do is down in this guy here I'm
going to for example draw a horizontal
line like so okay I don't know what's
happening on the left or the right but I
know around there there's a stationary
point so that's why it looks kind of
flat okay now then my next question is
do I go up after the stationary point or
do I go down I'm flat and then I'm gonna
go one way or the other which way
am I gonna get [ __ ] or am I gonna go down
I'll think about it what information
does the graph tell me after this
stationary point what does this gradient
here tell me can you tell me about the
sign the positive negative of the
gradient at that point what's this this
is positive right if a gradient is
positive what does that tell you about
the original graph gradients positive
that means that you should be going up
right that's an increasing function so
in other words after this stationary
point here this one here the next thing
I should do is go up okay in fact that
means I'm going to start a little bit
lower like down here and I'm going to
start going up like so and does that
make sense I started low and I'm going
high okay I'm heading towards this other
vertical line here what happens in that
vertical line what was why was it
important to me there's a there's
another stationary point that Mahane
towards right so as I head up you better
slow down if you want to get to that
stationary point because otherwise
you're gonna hit the wall right so I
slowed down until I get to that
stationary point do you see how I worked
out what was going on between these two
number one I knew there were two
stationary points number two I knew that
between them I was going up because my
grading was positive hopefully now you
can fill in the rest of the gaps how do
I know that this is the shape on this
side what information in this graph here
the gradient tells me that yeah go ahead
fantastic so we don't have the algebra
here but that doesn't mean you can't use
all your algebraic intuition so you're
like I started with a parabola I think
this is gonna be a cubic but another
part of the graph told you to confirm
that right have a look down here look at
this section of the gradient this
section here let me shade it in a color
to make it really obvious what's the
sign of the gradient in this section
it's negative right which should tell
you what about the original function
it's got one down it's decreasing you
see that do you see how it's decreasing
and you see the same thing over here on
this side that guy's also decreasing so
that's why I know this should be the
rest of the shape okay
so well done if you got something
roughly like that does anyone have any
questions yeah okay just one last thing
you might notice where I've drawn my
graph do you think it would make a
difference if I drew the graph up here
would it make a difference if it was
higher or lower some of you shaking your
head why I'm only graphing the gradient
the gradient is the same between this
graph I just showed you and this graph
which is way lower the position doesn't
change
it's the steepness the gradient that
matters okay that will come really
important in a few months a file in the
back you mind